most of the time you have no need to be
any fitter than you already are
i know this because you are alive and
hearing this we have adapted to our
environments
and that's just fine but problems occur
when that environment changes in a rapid
and unpredictable manner
that's why it pays to be not only fit
enough for everyday life but also for
the unexpected events that could
occur are you fit enough if you crash
land on a desert island
are you fit enough when someone breaks
into your home how about if a friend
injures themselves while you're on a
hike what about the ever-present danger
of a zombie apocalypse
or worse yet what if someone asks you to
help them move home
these are just silly scenarios for the
most part but they do provide a useful
thought experiment
they force us to reflect on our training
and ask whether it is truly
offering the most benefit to our overall
performance
following are some basic capabilities
that i think everyone should train for
of course physical or mental handicaps
may mean that these traits aren't
available to everyone
and the list is by no means
comprehensive but hopefully they might
provide a useful framework
through which to view training and some
goals to aspire to
can you in the event of an emergency
remain calm
the first thing that will determine your
usefulness in nearly any emergency
will be your ability to remain calm you
might be injured scared or upset
but you need to recenter and focus if
you're going to rally others and come up
with a useful plan of action
in fact remaining calm can even help you
to become more resourceful and creative
this has been shown in studies where
more relaxed approaches to problem
solving
allow the participants to overcome the
cognitive bias functional fixedness
how do we train for this it turns out
that meditation is a powerful tool for
improving emotional awareness and
control
by practicing focus we can choose not to
focus on feelings of anxiety or despair
interestingly at least one study
suggests that practicing any form of
extended focus
can have similar effects even rehearsing
mental maths
you can also desensitize yourself to
stress to a certain degree this is
something that special operations
training focuses heavily on
react quickly in my john wick video i
discussed topics such as sports vision
visual processing and attentional
blindness we saw that by training the
working memory and using tools like 3d
object tracking tasks
it is possible to increase awareness of
the visual field
these skills are likewise developed by
certain team sports
and those athletes may supplement this
training with drills involving a
reaction ball
juggling is a great skill that we can
also use for a similar benefit
lift and carry a heavy object lifting an
object is a useful ability
whether that means lifting an obstacle
or moving an injured ally
but in most scenarios where you must
lift something you also need to move it
some distance
more often you'll need to walk with said
object strength endurance is as
important as max strengthen
as is the core stability and hip
stability necessary to move while under
a heavy load
moreover we must be able to lift
uncooperative objects at awkward angles
we can train this by lifting sandbags
kettlebells and bulgarian bags
weights that shift and move and that
make the challenge slightly different
every single time
we can use farmers walks and loaded
carries to practice travelling with
those weights
this is what nikolai bernstein referred
to as repetition without repetition
such that we are not strong and capable
in just one highly refined and sterile
range
run far the first rule of zombieland is
cardio
this is actually a very realistic first
rule given that the ability to outrun
danger
would probably correlate pretty directly
with your chances of survival
the ability to run a long way also
suggests good cardiovascular fitness
nothing replaces steady state cardio
when it comes to improving that kind of
endurance
humans are built to run so this should
form a part of any complete training
program
this can develop something called your
q-max which isn't trained with hiit
better yet we should run on varied
terrain so as to create a more dynamic
skill that won't be as likely to cause
i.t band pain and other problems
run fast the ability to outrun danger
is one of the most crucial for surviving
a catastrophe whether that's out running
a fire or a missed bus
sometimes that means moving very quickly
from point a to point b which is a full
body movement that requires a strong
core
hip stabilization ankle stiffness and
explosive power
traverse any terrain humans should be
able to traverse any kind of terrain
they might encounter
that also means being able to move
vertically up trees over walls or onto
boulders and cliff faces
there are several exercises you can use
to improve climbing skill
rope climbs muscle ups and pavel
satsulin's tactical pull up
all mimic that mounting motion of course
nothing beats
actual rock climbing which also trains
the grip to a tremendous degree
likewise everyone who is able should
learn to swim another aspect relating to
traversal is your equilibrioception
can you balance along a thin beam can
you remain upright as the world is
crashing down around you finally we must
be able to jump
what's important here is strength to
weight ratio is of no use being
incredibly strong
if you're so heavy you can't climb the
stairs or perform a pull-up if you can
squat a huge amount of weight but can't
jump
maybe it's time to lighten that load and
focus more on bar's speed
maybe it's time to try lifting that
weight on one leg which is how we more
often propel ourselves
running climbing and jumping give us
more options for three-dimensional
movement
in any environment it literally
increases your physical freedom
and creates new escape routes and
vantage points
find your way navigation might seem like
an odd trait to include here
it's certainly something that i need to
work on myself but this is also a
fundamental human capacity
and one that was once crucial to our
survival there are countless modern
situations too where survival hinges on
navigation
we can't always rely on our phones which
might also actually be dulling our
internal compass
like an atrophied muscle thankfully this
is once again something that can be
trained
interestingly increasing testosterone
may even enhance our internal compass
also fascinating is the possibility of
inbuilt magnetoreception in humans
the ability to sense direction based on
the earth's natural magnetic fields
remember details likewise the ability to
retain and retrieve information is often
fundamental
forgetting that crucial detail could be
the difference between life and death
what's often just as important as recall
is perspective memory
remembering to remember prospective
memory can be trained
we can train this by setting ourselves
arbitrary tasks for the day
and then grading our performance this
has been demonstrated in a number of
studies
communicate negotiate and lead soft
skills such as persuasion negotiation
building trust and blending in are
likewise called upon in countless
scenarios
these skills are coveted by the cia and
are trained with drills like perfect
stranger
according to the big breach by xmi6
agent richard tomlinson
this exercise involves trying to get the
name contact details and passport number
of a random person in a pub
simply by talking to them could you do
it remain focused
psychomotor vigilance focus is a
critical gateway to many of the traits
we've explored so far
focus is crucial for reactions for
balance for memory for emotional control
and so much more
again focus can be trained like a muscle
but it's overlooked by many
once again we can train focus with
meditation focus can also be heightened
in the moment if we can achieve a state
of flow
learn quickly someone who can learn
quickly a so-called super learner
can gain the abilities they need for a
given situation this means not only
learning new concepts and gaining new
knowledge
but also learning new physical skills
learning is a product of your way of
thinking specific tools and strategies
can be employed to improve the process
so-called accelerated learning
techniques but we can also learn to
develop our plasticity
the brain's variability to reshape
itself and encode new information
the best way we do this is by continuing
to learn which keeps the brain plastic
overcome an opponent if you can
negotiate run and traverse your
environment
you can hopefully avoid the physical
confrontation however there will always
be the possibility that you need to
defend yourself or others
does your physical toolkit provide the
traits that will improve your odds of
coming out on top
aim throw and catch hand-eye
coordination and the ability to propel
objects over distance
was crucial to survival during our
evolution and it's still important to be
able to track a target
predict the trajectory of an object
through space and arrange yourself
around that accordingly
again this can be trained with practice
we should also expose ourselves to as
many physical interactions as possible
to develop the inbuilt physics
prediction model we keep in our
pre-motor cortex
actively recover active recovery is an
overlooked ability that can enhance
performance in nearly any physical task
the ability to quickly recover from a
punishing experience is what allows you
to consistently perform your best
this is another distinguishing feature
of the very top performers in the
military
and athletics coach jc santana from the
institute of human performance
even talks about how he helps his
fighters get strategic rest
during a fight problem solve
creativity can be weaponized to solve a
problem or even to discover new
opportunities
again we can practice and develop our
creativity but this is also a product of
being able to remain calm
to approach problems with an open mind
to think outside the box and overcome
cognitive biases and to draw from a
large well of information and former
knowledge
using these traits in isolation is not
enough though we must be able to
dynamically shift between them and apply
them in countless combinations
if you can excel in the areas i've
listed here you will be extremely
adaptable to a wide variety of
unpredictable scenarios
this is what georges hebert describes as
being strong to be helpful
this is being ready for anything and
this is what i believe it means to be
truly fit
[Music]
so there you go guys i hope that video
was useful and interesting this is
actually a deviation from my planned
content schedule this month because i
had a
flood in my house and i'm currently
staying at the in-laws with minimal
equipment so hopefully i can get this
video out on time
if it's a week late then i can only
apologize i just think it's useful to
sometimes think about
why you're fit and what the purpose of
all these different traits we're
developing
actually might be i hope it starts a
discussion and i hope you guys found it
interesting
if you guys agree with these ideas and
you want to train in a way that's
actually useful and
could benefit you in a crisis then why
not check out my ebook and training
program
super functional training where i go
into this stuff in much more detail
an outline at the end a program that
will develop not only your strength and
speed but your mobility
your brain power and a whole lot more
alternatively you could check out my
physical book which was recently
published functional training
and beyond that's available from all
good bookstores and it contains a
large discussion around the philosophy
of functional training
as well as many different practical
tools you can use from a whole diverse
range of training modalities either way
thanks so much for watching this one
guys
please leave a comment and share it
around that helps me out a whole ton
subscribe if you want to see more like
this and hit the notification bell if
you want to be
notified of new uploads and yeah i'll
catch you next time
bye for now